sac à dos cartes géographiques et
appareils photos ce sont des
explorateurs d'un nouveau genre qui se
sont retrouvés samedi à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines
ils sont une centaine à s'être déplacés
parfois de très loin pour venir
découvrir l'agglomération yvelinoise
j'ai trouvé l'initiative très bien quoi
de pouvoir visiter la banlieue de
manière intelligente et de redécouvrir
en fait que ce qu'on ignore je dois dire
qu'en fait je jamais mis les pieds ici à
saint quentin je sais que de l'ouvrier
avait fait quelque chose d'important
historiquement sur l'aménagement et et
du plan est donc en fait l'idée c'est de
voir ce que c'est devenu quoi est ce que
je fais aujourd'hui c'est ma troisième
rando avec cette organisation
et puis oui comme je connais pas cette
partie de l'île de france je suis ravi
de participer avec métropolitain à cette
randonnée que je ne ferais pas seul on
peut passer aussi bien d'un immeuble un
champ à une mare 1-1 grives hier c'est
extraordinaire jacques dor découverte
des arcades de la sourderie puis
direction la ville de trappes en passant
par la colline des longs cours et
l'abbaye des templiers
depuis deux ans le collectif le voyage
métropolitain organise ces randonnées
d'un nouveau genre
une fois par mois il offre ainsi aux
participants la possibilité sur un ou
deux jours de se rencontrer d'échanger
mais surtout d'appréhender un territoire
différemment
l'objectif c'est de prendre un peu de
recul aussi sur son propre espace de vie
en considérant l'agglomération
parisienne comme un espace de vie c'est
à dire c'est une entité urbaine
cohérente ou pas mais qui a beaucoup de
fragmentation spatiale sociale et donc
en fait encore du très peu cette énorme
ville
les futurs voyages métropolitain se
dérouleront à bonneuil sur marne ou
encore près de melun
une manière de voyager à seulement
quelques kilomètres de chez soi